you said you you did the sniper you did
a bunch of different uh
uh uh courses and schools that you took
when you were training with the marines
yourself what did you ever take anything
with marines that was as tough
uh as buzz was was there anything that
he did with marines recently there's
this one training i took with them it
kicked my ass it was the closest thing
to
you know being a navy seal
oh yeah for sure um you know
the
you know marine corps sniper school was
uh definitely one of the toughest
courses i've ever been to uh
it's uh you know the attrition rate's
just about the same uh you know the
marines hi they hold that school in a
very high regard so they make sure that
people who pass it have earned it uh
you know and it was i had no you know
i didn't grow up with guns i didn't grow
up shooting uh so ever i was learning
everything on the fly um you know as far
as becoming an infantryman or just being
a comfortable round gun so it was pretty
challenging
but you know i made it through that and
then the marine corps water survival
school is definitely
the toughest water school i've been to
it's uh no joke about five weeks
and uh when you come out of there you're
you feel like a fish what's what's tough
about it like if you were to kind of
give us a you know
so
i'll give you like just a normal day uh
you show up uh you do uh you swim 2 000
meters uh with full camis uh every 500
meters you take off a piece of your
camis and then uh
by the end of that 2000 they are tying
all of your clothes together they've
tied all your clothes together at the
bottom of the pool the deep end then
they you have a certain amount of time
to find your clothes and put them back
on and then you get classes all day but
the classes you're treading water the
whole time while the instructor's
outside teaching outside of the pool
teaching the class
and then at the end of the day you do
they call it uh you know pt but uh it's
in the pool so it's like an hour and a
half to two hours of just straight uh
exercises in the pool breathing
exercises sprints that's after the 2000
meters with full gear on and every 500
meters you take a piece off oh yeah so
you're uh you come out of there like
super in shape super comfortable in the
water um you know that had a pretty good
attrition rate as well
for people that were quitting
wow so if you like this sort of short
clip from an interview i did click over
here to watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]